british support for ukraine in action
hundreds of ukrainian troops have
secretly been training in the uk
these the first images of them learning
to operate desperately needed weapons
crucial to defeat russia's invasion
it's been a key theme in the summit of
nato allies this week
so too is shoring up the alliance's own
defenses despite russian threats
britain's prime minister sounded defiant
at least he tried to
together
to ease can you hear me
he revealed spending on the uk's armed
forces will rise by billions of pounds
we need to invest for the long term in
vital capabilities like future combat
air while simultaneously adapting to a
more dangerous and more competitive
world and the logical conclusion of the
investments on which uh we propose to
embark
of these decisions is that we will reach
2.5 percent of gdp on defense by the end
of the decade
but critics warn this is too slow as the
danger is now
boris johnson said the head of nato had
agreed to look at increasing a wider
target for defence spending by all
allies up from just two percent though
that didn't look set to happen anytime
soon either
and then i'm certain that when we
are even closer to 2024 which is the
deadline for our current commitment we
will have an important discussion innate
about uh what would be the next target
yet this summit has delivered genuine
changes
most notably an invitation to
historically neutral sweden and finland
to join the alliance
the u.s president described this as the
ultimate blow for vladimir putin he's
also pledging thousands more troops and
weapons to defend europe
putin thought he could break the
transatlantic alliance
he tried to weaken us
he expected our resolve to fracture
but he's getting exactly what he did not
want what formed
but russia has warned of a new iron
curtain descending on europe the
president here on a visit to
turkmenistan busy
the images on the mind of nato allies
though is what russia is doing in
ukraine and what more it could do to
them if their new plans fail debra
haynes sky news madrid